rejoin it was one of president biden's
first promises
to rejoin the paris agreement on climate
change now confirmed with a signature
and a pledge
we can no longer delay or do the bare
minimum
to address climate change this is a
global
existential crisis
and we'll all suffer we'll all suffer
the consequences if we fail
we have to rapidly accelerate our
commitments to aggressively curb our
emissions
and to hold one another accountable for
meeting our goals
and increasing our ambitions america has
a new climate change envoy
clearly furious that donald trump ever
left this agreement
we have to be honest that as a global
community we're not close to where we
need to be
we have to be humble because we know the
united states was
inexcusably absent for four years and
most of all
we have to be ambitious all of us
because we have to get the job
done in texas there's still snow on the
roads and oil in the ground
we came here to the town of kilgore a
place synonymous with the oil industry
back in the 1930s there were 24 oil
wells in this
one stretch of road it was known as the
richest acre in the world
there were more than a thousand worlds
in this one
town and that cheap plentiful supply of
oil
fueled america's expansion it's now in
the nation's dna
which is why weaning america of its
addiction
to cheap fossil fuels is going to be
hard
because for the people here it's not
just about the environment but about
jobs
livelihoods and the suspicion that this
vast country is not ready to give up on
fossil fuels
i'll tell you about the wind powers
that's what's going on right now
everything's frozen up
they still use oil guess what they went
out to defrost them with
a helicopter that uses oil how do they
get the oil
from the ground i mean
that we're years away from stuff like
that for renewable
resources being from around here oil is
everything
and and being from kilgore i know a lot
of people whose livelihood depend on oil
i think it's fine to look for
alternative sources but
until there's a until there's a way to
adequately
adequately produce those alternative
sources and
i feel like we should still use a hole
five and a half billion barrels of oil
have come out of the ground in east
texas
these lands have fueled the country for
nearly a century
the time is changing look up there in
those old oil derricks
the vultures are gathering adam parsons
sky news
kilgore in texas